[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris mannix senior nba writer for uh
sports illustrated set to join us chris
let me start with we'll get to the
lakers and some of this other stuff here
in a moment but i'm going to ask you
about uh you know teams not showing up
in the playoffs and then they say well
you know we just didn't have effort last
night uh
you know what do you make of that when
you hear that excuse
zeroing in on the sixers right like
embiid you can explain like he's got a
broken face
and every time he gets touched in that
face
it clearly
causes him
an incredible amount of pain so i think
that's why
he wasn't the physical player we're used
to seeing
uh throughout most of the season because
you know he starts banging down there
and
the pain ratchets up but it's a lot of
pain to be and have a broken orbital
bone even with a mask on
the guy you can't understand and can't
explain is james harden like
what is james harden doing like what is
james harden at this point he teased us
in game four damn with with that 31
points he was play making he looked like
the james harden of old in that game
four
and then he comes out against miami in
game five
and is a complete no-show like he's i i
just i don't know what i can to expect
from james harden
every single night and that's
frightening for the sixers not just
going into this elimination game but
then going into the offseason because
you got to pay this guy
and
you got to tie yourself to him for maybe
a quarter of a billion dollars
over the next five years like he's
it's really frustrating watching james
harden play that well in game four
and then be completely overwhelmed in
game five that tells me james harden is
a really diminished version of the
player we saw in houston three of these
five games he has gone under 20 points
that can't happen if you want to be a
max player in this league okay but why
does philadelphia have to then spend a
quarter of a billion dollars on a guy
who is going to provide diminishing
returns okay but what are you going to
do what's the alternative if he can get
like all it takes is one
bonkers team out there to give james
hard an offer in the off season and he
could disappear for nothing and that
would leave you with no ben simmons but
would they be a better team without him
though chris i i would have said
so
no is the short answer because
he walks away it's not like you create
all this flexibility to go out and sign
somebody else like your your options
got severely limited
when you traded all those assets to get
it not only giving up ben but seth curry
who was great the two first-round draft
picks you're limited dan like there's
only so much you can do now they have to
hope
that
they can
that there's some negotiation
there you know james has that i think
it's 47 million in the player option
last year of his contract i'm sure he
doesn't want to opt out of that
unless he's guaranteed
you know it's almost like a chris paul
situation right where chris opted out
but he got the four years 120 million
dollars
on that deal like i think the sixers got
to hope
that
james harden comes to the table
with a realistic mindset of what he's
worth but he's not worth that
277 million total that he could
potentially get on a new deal that
there's some kind of middle ground that
they can all agree to where the sixers
can stomach these diminishing returns
chris mannix covers the nba senior
writer for sports illustrated uh john
morant probably not going to play
tonight against the golden state
warriors uh your assessment of the play
by jordan poole was it called correctly
you know i i think it was called
correctly
and
when i've talked talk to people around
the league about jordan poole like he
doesn't have
this reputation for
playing like that it was a weird play
but
it's hard for me to get to the to this
place dan
where in that split second
where jordan poole is double teaming
john marantz
he reaches over and pulls on the knee
that's been bothering john morant for so
long i just can't get there like i don't
know what was going through his mind
in that moment i think going for a steal
or even
trying to be a little bit sneaky be
physical grab something to try to get to
that ball was going through his mind but
i can't get there where it was some kind
of play where jordan poole was trying
to hurt john morant i think it was just
bad luck bad play but bad luck for for
the grizzlies and john moran
uh
lakers don't have a coach yet
who are they waiting for
i don't know
you know there's a lot
try to get a read in the lakers
there's a lot of mark jackson talk
that's out there right now um i'm not
really buying that because i don't think
that rob polenka
uh wants to hire mark jackson um
i i don't know which direction they're
gonna go they want a veteran coach i
know that um i don't know which veteran
coach is out there quinn snyder
you know he had his end of the season
availability earlier this week and
didn't exactly confirm he'd be back you
know wasn't wasn't there and i think
quinn snyder would rock it towards the
top of the list
if he became a coaching free agent he's
got the relationship with the bus family
from his time
coaching in south bay and he's that not
a championship coach
but an established coach so i think quin
snyder
would be up there but i don't think
they're very close
to making that higher i mean dad did did
you read
plaschke's column with genie bus this
week did you look at that did you hear
what genie said in that column
no
well it was it was interesting um
you know she's
she basically admitted to
fielding all this advice from all the
people we thought she was fielding
advice from from magic johnson from phil
jackson to
having unflinching faith in
this front office it was wild because
you know what my biggest criticism of
the lakers linda linda rambis kurt
rambis the people there like my biggest
criticism of the lakers
is that they are the marquee franchise
in the nba and they are being run like a
mom-and-pop outfit that they are not
going out there
and
looking for the best and the brightest
like kurt rambis has decades of
experience in the nba
but almost none of it is good experience
like his years as an nba coach were not
successful and to be
taking advice from phil jackson who
was an excellent coach
but
a horrifyingly bad general manager
like his wild magic johnson quit on the
team and is still lobbing grenades at
the team
from the first take desk like i don't
i just don't understand like this is an
organization that has the resources to
go to oklahoma city and say here's a
blank chase one of those publishers
clearing house checks sam presti you
fill in the number and saying sam you
run our organization i don't know if you
take it i kind of assume he would
because it's the lakers um but they
won't do it and i don't i understand
that like if you're gonna look for why
the lakers
can't work their way back into
championship contention
it's because they keep making these
bizarre decisions that
empower
kurt rambis that
involve linda rambas in an interesting
way that
um you know involve you know rob
polenka's he said this rob polenka's
basketball operations staff includes two
members of the bus family not even
jeanne two other members of the bus i
just i just don't get it i don't get why
if you're the lakers you're not
operating more like the clippers like
you look at the clippers front office
you know lawrence frank's a basketball
lifer but he's surrounded by really
smart guys whether it was michael winger
trent redden uh even bringing in my good
friend lee jenkins to play a role in
that front office like they're just
operating the clippers operate like a
functional big market franchise and the
lakers operate like something else and i
don't i don't really understand why yeah
those are great points you know you
start to look at this and we want to
blame russell westbrook for last year
okay you can blame him what about all
the other years where you didn't do
anything other than you won the title in
the bubble i mean this is a decade uh
you know going back to kobe where
you know they you got to go out and see
kobe and that was it you know this was
they become a losing franchise which is
amazing to be
they're almost like the dallas cowboys
in a sense that they're so popular we
keep waiting for them to win or the
yankees every year yankees haven't done
anything cowboys haven't done anything
the lakers haven't done anything except
for the bubble title and people look
people think i'm overly
i praise danny ainge too much sometimes
but like
danny angel would have traded kobe in a
heartbeat danny angel would have let
kobe walk or whatever he would never
have
allowed those last two years to take
place where it was just the kobe show
and that like you said that was it um i
just i just don't understand it like
this is
you know like lakers fans don't want to
hear this either but you overpaid for
anthony davis like you had leverage you
know because a.d only wanted to go to la
and you gave up the store to go get
davis i just don't understand it like
this is
you know i i appreciate genie bus
um
respecting loyalty and wanting to keep
that inner circle tight especially when
it's filled with like a laker legend
like uh magic and phil jackson's got a
lot of equity within that organization
but
you know you've gotta
put all that aside you've got to hire
the very best and empower the very best
to do that job that's not what the
lakers are doing and ultimately if this
team
doesn't succeed in the next three or
four years that's probably going to be
the reason why
enjoy the game tonight chris thanks for
joining us as always you got it dad
chris mannix pretty strong opinions
there